hello and welcome to this video playing
vadas katha Wow
madatha what Rahula wow that's info okay
does not play the check on YouTube I
think this is more more testing okay
this is also okay of course one white is
doing but I would go Queenie to check
you've given the chance that it looks
for audio but this is how this opening
is played Quincy - now is the most
interesting choice okay yeah thank you
should at 5 then if given the
opportunity I'd do that
before it's a little bit odd peon
shadowing here with white it's not the
most obvious choice 94 he will take and
go d5 I guess that is actually a little
bit it's not bad actually not so bad
okay so let's do it like just on general
terms I would like to trade minor pieces
typical entire iqp strategy
you just have to always check of your
general strategy is also applying to the
position that you have and this is very
unlikely to be good because two minor
pieces traded that should favor me quite
substantially so here I'm angling for 95
and if he goes ported if I just take it
because of the discovered check on h2 so
I should be able to put 95 put the
knight on to d5 next and then his Bishop
looks a little bit passive 95s almost
impossible to play as a pre move
okay so Knight to d5
from Knight to e5 I mean should probably
prevent not a big problem but if you can
prevent it make sense to do so
Queen to f6
keeping 95 out of this position now
wonder if white should go CLE five you
know that Justin I don't know I still
plays it why is that possible
take take cooked eggs hmm it's got a bit
of activity yeah so I still don't
believe it
you taking a cent upon
I don't see any and he sing here for
white the knight on d5 is just Rock him
to the covering c7 and c6 I mean if I
get seasick sets very nice and then the
Knights cupboard covers c7 everything's
looking very harmonious I don't see
anything concrete that white has he and
I really don't know so c6
maybe I didn't didn't really have a um
Bishop c3 now would you know that forces
forces the trade I would have liked to
keep my knives with
I would have liked to keep the night but
wasn't possible yeah why should probably
go for the rook ending it's not very
attractive to play but it's better than
the other scenarios it looks very good
though
for me
yeah just here right
what is the quickest make quickest is
not really important the most convincing
way to play I mean he cannot move the
rook somewhere without dropping the
apron yeah we'll see three chicken now
it's not a big problem
that's probably when you resign right
you know yeah I think he from here he
started to miss play this position a
little bit quick Quincy to is what they
normally play in such a position trying
to prevent if we check this trying to
prevent Bishop f5 and cannot do that and
it's important to see that white is also
eyeing the possibility to play Bishop
takes h6 for example if a player will
create he will take him and that is a
disaster
yeah like should not do that yeah Quincy
to is usually the way to go
yeah trying to play with this Bishop
takes h6 i diem yeah before yeah the
bishop is just not a good PCM it looks
at this pawn 94 I wasn't so certain
about and in fact the engine strongly
dislikes the move because of the caption
okay and one did not think about this
all that much but yeah yeah you see what
the problem is if I want to keep this
active piece I need to go here but that
is not really great yeah that is that is
a nice initiative here and here and
that's what he should have done so 94 is
not so good I probably should do this
this is the most normal move maybe if
white is doing something very even
nobody would play that right like this F
I can even take on h3
so something something like this is just
not working it hangs and
thing yeah Oh Kim so he had a rupee one
but Bishop d3 is very comfortable for me
now I can trade two minor pieces and now
I get to d5 he cannot go d5 because I
just take it and that's the discovery so
very comfortable and now I try to
prevent ninety five and then he played
it anyway
yeah I mean it's just a corner and I
should take it I mean it should not
really panic with white it's a little
bit uncomfortable here
because you have no activity for the
isolated pawn and what it's not really
ideal with the bishop on d2 you have
those two pawns
if white would have the pawn still on b2
a2 I wouldn't even think that this is
anything for black because with white
you trade down the heavy pieces and you
can draw this ending rather comfortably
not much fun but you should draw it and
yeah here it's a little bit awkward
because many endings you will have a
pretty bad Bishop yes still 95 is not
called for it's just erm yeah it's
panicking and with that without the
reason yeah maybe Queen to f5 is
stronger just keep the knowledge this
sorry Bishop c3 is a good idea just to
trade the good strong night and then we
got we got to the to the ending and yeah
it is it is awkward I have got the more
active rook and you have a weakness is
on b4 on a3 and my king is quite quickly
approaching I think it's just lost don't
see any great defensive resource I think
it's just the lost ending it's not much
that what can do okay guys thanks for
watching